[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन
गुड इवनिंग तू जो
वेलकम
[संगीत]
टॉपिक स्टार्ट करते हैं
चलो फिर कंटिन्यू करते फिर से वही है एक
बार आपको लोगों को याद दिल देता हूं जैसे
हमारी क्लास खत्म हो जाएगी आप लोगों को
क्या करना है हमारे वीडियो डिस्क्रिप्शन
के अंदर लिंकडइन पेज अवेलेबल है वहां पर
जाइए और वापस जान के बाद आपको हमारा
पेज मिलेगा देखने को ये तो मेरी ऑप्शनल
आइडिया है बट ऐसे ही कुछ इलेक्ट्रॉनिक
नहीं सकते सबको देखने को मिलेगा वहां पर
जाइए जैसे ही वीडियो खत्म हो जाति है उसके
बाद आप डेट 12
किमी उसके साथ यह अपडेट हो जाएगा हमारा
वेब पेज और आपको जाना है वहां पर कमेंट
में करके कमेंट आउट करके बताना की आज का
हमारा टॉपिक किया था आज हमने क्या शिखा है
जो कंटिन्यू हमारे कमेंट करता है इसके बाद
कोई सपोर्ट नहीं करता है कोई कमेंट आउट
नहीं करता
जितनी बार उतना कम करेंगे
चलो फिर कंटिन्यू करते हैं आज हमारा टॉपिक
है मैं पहले बताता हूं एक लॉकेट कमांड है
और दूसरा आपको सिखाऊंगा मैं की जो पैकेज
हैं वह कैसे इंस्टॉल करते हैं कैसे लिस्ट
करते हैं उन सबके बड़े में सीखने वाले हैं
की पैकेज को कैसे हैंडल करना है आपकी मशीन
में पैकेज मैनेजमेंट बिल्कुल एक बेसिक
लेवल पर तो डेट की कभी भी आपको पैकेज
इंस्टॉल करना पसंद है आपकी मशीन में उसे
रिलेटेड कोई प्रॉब्लम आई है तो वो आपको
पता चल जाए की ओके ये प्रॉब्लम हो शक्ति
है उसके बाद टाइम रात तो हम कुछ और कुछ
ऑपरेटर के बड़े में सीखने वाले हैं
आज का
तो हम बात करते हैं
तो हम अपने टर्मिनल पर ए जाते हैं
फाइल को सर्च करने के लिए और यह पता लगाने
के लिए की वह फाइल हमारे सिस्टम में कहां
पर होगी
लॉकेट कमांड को उसे करने का बहुत ही आसन
तरीका है और यह बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट कमांड भी
हमारे लिए
सबसे पहले चीज जो लॉकेट कमांड के बड़े में
हमको पता होना चाहिए वह
सर्च करने के लिए हमारे सिस्टम में
प्रेजेंट एक लोकल डेटाबेस है उसका उसे
करते हैं क्या होता है की जितने
होती हैं डिलीट होती हैं मॉडिफाई होती है
कुछ भी होता है
लिंग का मतलब या आप लिंग नहीं है
लोकल डेटाबेस मेंटेन किया जाता है
किसी भी फाइल को फाइंड अप करने के लिए
क्या करता है आपके आउटपुट सर्च
जहां-जहां पर जिस-जिस बात पर आपको आउटपुट
मिलेगा उसको क्या करेगा ये आपकी स्क्रीन
पर प्रिंट कर देगा पर एग्जांपल हम लोग
देखते हैं अमल लॉकेट करता हूं
लॉकेट कमल का नाम है लॉकेट उसके बाद मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं स्टार स्टार का मतलब होता
जो एक ग्लोबल पैरामीटर है ग्लोबल
के लिए उसे किया जाता है इसका क्या मतलब
है की ये जितने भी मतलब स्टोर जो डॉट कॉम
मतलब क्या है की और में डॉट कॉम होना
चाहिए और उससे पहले कुछ भी हो कुछ भी हो
की कोई भी फाइल हो उनको लॉकेट करना है
लेकिन हमें स्क्रीन पर कौन सा आउटपुट
प्रिंट आउट होना चाहिए की वह साड़ी
प्रिंट हनी चाहिए
जिनके पीछे
देखने को आपको मिल रहा है तो यह आपकी
ऊंचाई फाइल्स को प्रिंट करके दिखा देगा
स्कैन के ऊपर देखिए जितनी भी फाइल्स के और
में
टोटल कितनी है काउंट करके दिखाऊं तो देखिए
हम काउंट कर भी सकते हैं डब्लू सी आईफोन ल
यह देखिए
1640 दिखाइए
हेलो
किट आईफोन
था अब देखिए यहां पर क्या है कैपिटल सी है
स्मॉल लो है कैपिटल स स्मॉल एफ है अब ये
मटर नहीं करता की आप कैसे सेंसटिविटी
क्योंकि हमने आई मतलब इग्नोर कर दीजिए
10 देखने हैं वो भी हम देख सकते हैं तन भी
देख सकते हैं इसकी जगह हम 10 रिजल्ट
अब हमें पता है की लोग जो लॉकेट कमांड है
ना वह डेटाबेस को उसे करती है हमारे
पैटर्न
या फाइल्स को फाइंड आउट करने के लिए
अब हमारे यह जो डेटाबेस है तब तक ही
यूजफुल है जब तक इसके अंदर की इनफॉरमेशन
अप तू डेट है लेकिन बाय डिफॉल्ट क्या होता
है की अगर हम रियल सर्वर की बात करें तो
दिन में एक बार ही अपडेट होता है क्योंकि
सर्वर का भी ऑफ तो होते ही नहीं और हमारी
मशीन की बात करते हैं तो आपकी मशीन जब भी
पावर ऑन होती है तो इस टाइम पर ये डेटाबेस
अपडेट होता है इसका मतलब यह है की कुछ भी
में टाइम में हो रहा है में टाइम का मतलब
चाहे कोई भी फाइल क्रिएट हो रही है या
डिलीट हो रही है या मुंह हो रही है या वो
डेटाबेस के अंदर
लोग ही लोग इन ही नहीं होती मतलब क्या है
की जैसे आपका डेटाबेस अपडेट हुआ एक ही बार
होता है आपकी मशीन हुई अब मेरी मशीन अभी
चलो एक घंटे से ऑन है तो अगर मैं अभी
अपडेट हुआ होगा इसके बाद नेक्स्ट जब तक
मेरी मशीन 1 घंटा चलेगी दो घंटा तक चलेगी
उसमें जितने भी फाइल क्रिएट
हुआ होगा जितनी फाइल डिलीट हो गई होगी या
अपडेट होगी या नहीं क्रिएट होगी वो उसे
डेट
सॉरी
तो साड़ी की साड़ी फाइल क्या है ना
डेटाबेस में अपडेट नहीं हुई होगी अब उनको
जब तक भी अपडेट नहीं होगी तब तक हो सकता
है की हम कोई ऐसी फाइल लॉकेट करने की
कोशिश कर रहे हैं वह फाइल डिलीट हो चुकी
है
क्योंकि डेटाबेस में वो अवेलेबल है लेकिन
में टाइम में क्या हो गया फाइल डिलीट हो
गई तो ऐसा भी हो सकता है तो हमें क्या
करना चाहिए हमेशा एक चीज ध्यान रखना आपको
हमेशा एक चीज ध्यान ध्यान में रखती है की
जब भी आप लॉकेट कमांड उसे करने वाले हो या
जब भी एक बार आपको लगता क्या
मुझे कुछ सर्च आउट करना है तो सिंपली
कमांड फायर कर दीजिए
लिंक भी थी उन लिंक भी थी वो साड़ी के
सारे क्या है इसके अंदर क्या होगी अपडेट
हो जाएंगे अभी अब
एक और ऑप्शन है इसमें सेफ्टी फीचर्स
यह है की
एक ऑप्शन उसे किया जाता है इसके साथ ऑप्शन
क्या करता है की हो सकता है
वो एग्जिट करती है नहीं करती अगर वो
एग्जिट करती है
तो इसलिए
इसमें वही आउटपुट स्क्रीन पर शो किया है
तो आपको पता चल गया होगा की लॉकेट कमांड
को कैसे उसे करना है और लॉकेट कमांड आप
देखना फाइल कमांड
हो सकता है की कभी भी आपको अपने मशीन में
कोई भी फाइल को सर्च करने की अचानक से
जुड़ी पद जाए तो आप कैसे कर पाओगे
वो आपके पास वैसे तो फाइंड कमांडर लॉकेट
कमांड भी है इसलिए मैंने आपको क्या है की
मल्टीप्लेक्स कमांड को आपके सामने शो किया
है रिप्रेजेंट किया है सो डेट की कभी भी
कोई कमांड भूल जाते हो तो दूसरे कमांड कोई
ना कोई कमांड आपके सामने याद रहेगी लोग
फाइंड आउट करना है मतलब लॉकेट कर सकते हैं
हम लॉकेट करने वाले क्या पता लॉकेट के नाम
से ही आपको लॉकेट का कम नाम है याद ए
जाएगा फाइंड के नाम से फाइंड का नाम याद ए
जाए तो इस प्रकार से हो सकता की आपको किसी
ने सोच से मुझे कुछ एक शब्द ग्रिप कर रहा
हूं की हां ग्रेप्स तो कमांड भी है तो ऐसे
कमांड आपको याद र जाएगी तो यह थी आपके एक
छोटी सी कमल लॉकेट कमल वेरी इंपॉर्टेंट
कमांड वेरी यूजफुल कमल अब बात करते हैं एक
छोटा सा इंट्रो एक छोटा सा पार्ट जो आपके
लिए इंपॉर्टेंट है आपको समझना बहुत ही
जरूरी है और आपको क्या के उससे ज्यादा
हमेशा रूबरू होते ही रहोगे की उसको उसे
करते ही करते हो डेली बेसिस पे आप साइबर
सिक्योरिटी
कर दो कोई भी हो उसको पैकेज हम उसको बोलते
हैं पैकेज मैनेजमेंट वेरी
वेरी वेरी इंपॉर्टेंट चाहे आप कहानी कम
करो अब डिपेंड करता है
देवयानी बेस ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
उसे करें तो आपको पैकेज क्या है की लास्ट
में डॉट आरपीएम देखने को मिलता है अगर
आपको फेडरल बेस्ड दे पैकेज आपको देखने को
उसे कर रहे हो तो आप जो भी होंगे पैकेज
आपको देखने को मिलेंगे लास्ट में मैं आपको
बताऊं तो ये रहा डॉट आर पीएम एक्सटेंशन
आपको देखने को मिलेंगे
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के अंदर
पेट्रोलिंग सिस्टम
एक्सटेंशन आपको देखने को मिलेगा वो लास्ट
में डीबी या डीपी के डीपी के जी आपको
देखने को मिलेगा अगर आपको
पैकेज का एक्सटेंशन देखना है
मैं आपको देखने को देगा बेस्ट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस हैं उनमें देव आपको देखने
को मिलेगा अब ये पैकेज क्या होता है
पर एग्जांपल
रिपोजिटरी क्या होती है क्या होती है की
कलेक्शन ऑफ सॉफ्टवेयर और डॉक्यूमेंट क्या
होती है पॉजिटिव
ठीक है
कलेक्शन ऑफ
सॉफ्टवेयर
और डॉक्यूमेंट
और कॉमर्स डाउनलोड
नॉर्मली गूगल प्रेफर करते हैं लेकिन
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट के लिए माइक्रोसॉफ्ट स्टोर
जो है उसके लिए वह अगर लेडिस की भाषा बोले
तो उसके लिए क्या है एक रिपोजिटरी है
क्योंकि उन्होंने क्या किया एक सेंट्रलाइज
किसी सर्वर के ऊपर उन साड़ी एप्लीकेशंस को
रखा हुआ है जो माइक्रोसॉफ्ट उसे करता है
या जो माइक्रोसॉफ्ट का उसे की जा शक्ति है
साड़ी चीज जो सपोर्ट करता है बेसिकली वो
साड़ी आपको देखने को मिलेगी तो आप क्या
सर्च करते हो डाउनलोड कर लेते हो और जो
नहीं मिलती वो आप क्या करते गूगल करते हो
ऐसे ही लाइनेक्स में काली लाइनेक्स में
क्या है की जितने भी क्योंकि कल अपने
रिपोर्ट की लोकेशन होती है उबंटू की अपनी
रिप्यूट की लोकेशन होती है और एवं जो आपका
पायलट होगा ऐसा उसकी अपनी रिपोजिटरी के
लोगों से होती है अब क्या होता है की
इन्होंने भी क्या किया सेंट्रलाइज अपना
सरवर बनाया हुआ है
है और उसे सर्वर को क्योंकि आप जब भी आपने
एक चीज अच्छी होगी जब भी आप अभी कॉन्फ़िगर
कर रहे थे और आपके सामने बहुत साड़ी
प्रॉब्लम्स देखने को मिल रही थी की जब आप
क्या कहते हो ईटीसी के अंदर एप्ट के अंदर
आप क्या देख रहे थे source.com लिस्ट वहां
पर क्या है कुछ कंफीग्रेशन करते थे वहां
पर एचटीटीपी करके कुछ एक एड्रेस डालते थे
वो एड्रेस क्या है वो रिपोजिटरी का एड्रेस
है वो मेंशन करता है की आपके लाइनेक्स
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के लिए यह काली लाइनेक्स
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के लिए आपको जो भी पैकेज
चाहिए या जो भी एप्लीकेशन से सॉफ्टवेयर
चाहिए वो आपको अगर डाउनलोड करने हैं तो वह
आपको यहां मिलेंगे और यह क्या है बहुत
बड़ा है ऐसा नहीं की
इसमें बहुत ज्यादा सॉफ्टवेयर अवेलेबल है
जो हमारी मशीन में हम इंस्टॉल भी नहीं
रहते वो हम रिटायरमेंट के अकॉर्डिंग
इंस्टॉल करते हैं तो रिप्यूट का मतलब यह
है इन्होंने भी अपनी और ऐसा नहीं की एक
बार उसमें स्टोर कर दे दी क्योंकि उसकी
कॉमेडी बहुत बड़ी है क्योंकि लाइनेक्स में
काली लाइनेक्स और लाइनेक्स है यह एक ऐसा
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम जो ओपन सोर्स प्लस
भी आपको कोई प्रॉब्लम आई है कहानी ना
कहानी आपको इसका सॉल्यूशन मिल जाता है और
वो ये सर कम करते हैं उसे कम्युनिटी में
उसको अपडेट करने का कोई पैकेज एक्सपायर हो
रहा है उसको अपडेट करना अपडेट करना और
साड़ी इसमें प्रोजेक्टर से ही तो करते हो
आप किसी भी कमांड के थ्रू आप काली ने सकी
कहां से अपडेट करते हो वहीं से करते
का मतलब क्या है की सेंट्रलाइज कलेक्शंस
है आपके सॉफ्टवेयर्स का और डॉक्यूमेंट का
और लाइनेक्स में सॉफ्टवेयर्स को हम बोलते
हैं पैकेज अब बात करते हैं की रिप्यूट की
रिटायरमेंट बेसिकली
सबसे ज्यादा जरूर पड़ी की आपकी डिपेंडेंसी
को कम करने के लिए अभी डिपेंडेंसी क्या
होती है
डिपेंडेंसी का मतलब होता है की किसी के
ऊपर डिपेंड होना अब हमारे मशीन है उसमें
कुछ ऐसे पैकेज होते हैं की जब वो आपकी
मशीन में इंस्टॉल होते हैं तो उनको
इंस्टॉल होने के लिए भी
किसी चीज के ऊपर डिपेंड होना पड़ता है
उसको बोलते
हैं डिपेंडेंसी
डिपेंडेंसी रिजॉल्व कैसे होगी पर एग्जांपल
आपने कोई सॉफ्टवेयर इंस्टॉल करना है कोई
भी पैकेज इंस्टॉल करना है ठीक है
डायरेक्टली अपने गूगल किया और वह आपने
क्या किया डाउनलोड करके और मैन्युअल उसको
अनपेक किया और इंस्टॉल करना स्टार्ट कर
दिया जैसे इंस्टॉल करना स्टार्ट किया उसने
बोला की मेरे को इंस्टॉल करने के लिए ये
मेरी आठ डिपेंडेंसी या फुलफिल कीजिए तभी
मैं इंस्टॉल होगा ओके
तो आपने वो आठ किया गूगल सर्च की और उनको
क्या है उनको इंस्टॉल करना पहले से
स्टार्ट कर दिया अब पता चला उन आठ की भी
अपनी डिपेंडेंसी है
है तो अब आप एक पैकेज को इंस्टॉल करने के
लिए
जहां पर एक पैकेट को इंस्टॉल करने के लिए
डिपॉजिटरी की हेल्प से आपको एक मिनट लगती
है अगर आपके इंटरनेट स्पीड ज्यादा है वहां
पर आपको पूरा दिन ग जाएगा और नो गाइनेटिक
या पूरा दिन में कर पाओगे या नहीं आपको दो
दिन तीन दिन ग जाएंगे सब एक पैकेज को
इंस्टॉल करना है के लिए वो रिप्रेजेंट वो
डिपेंडेंसी रिजॉल्व करते करते और तब तक वो
पैकेज इंस्टॉल नहीं होगा तब तक वो
डिपेंडेंसी रिजॉल्व नहीं होगी तो सब एक
बड़ा में कान ये भी है पालिटी कॉन्फ़िगर
करने का रिपोर्टर भी बना रहेगा की
डिपेंडेंसी डिपेंडेंसी आसानी
करते हैं तो आपको पता ही नहीं चला की
कितनी सिम चीज होगी उसे पैकेज की वो
ऑटोमेटेकली इस रिपोजिटरी से क्या करते हैं
जैसे ही आप कमांड फायर करते तो वो उधर से
ही उनको पता है की यहां मेरी रिपोर्ट है
यहां से ही मुझे साड़ी डिपेंडेंसी रिजॉल्व
हो जाति हो आप ऑटोमेटिक के लिए क्या है वो
इंस्टॉल हो जाति है और आपको पता ही नहीं
चला की कब आपका पैकेज इंस्टॉल हो गया अदर
वाइस कभी भी किसी भी एक पैकेज सॉल्व करके
देख लेना अपनी मशीन में तो आपकी सच में
हालात खराब हो जाएगी क्योंकि इतनी रिपोज
इतनी डिपेंडेंसी मिलेगी आप नहीं रेसल कर
पाओगे और सम टाइम्स कई बार ऐसा होता है की
कोई ऐसा पैकेज मिलता है की जो अपडेटेड हो
गया होगा तो उसके एक डिपेंडेंसी ऐसी ए
जाति है जो उसने पॉजिटिव में नहीं है उसकी
वजह से आपको क्या करना है कई बार आउटसोर्स
मतलब आपको गूगल से वो डिपेंडेंसी रिजॉल्व
करनी पड़ती है उसके बाद ही वो इंस्टॉल
होता है तो ये कुछ कम थे डिपॉजिटरीज के
लिए आई हो सबको पता चल गया होगी
रेफ्रिजरेटर क्या होती है डिपेंडेंसी क्या
होती है पैकेज हमलीनेस में सॉफ्टवेयर्स को
पैकेज बोलते हैं तो ये था आपका
छोटा सा एक इंट्रो अबाउट रिपोजिटरीज और
डिपेंडेंसी और पैकेज के बड़े में अब क्या
होता है ना की आपकी मशीन में इन
प्रेगनेंसी को क्या करने के लिए मैनेज
करने के लिए तीन कमांड का उसे किया जाता
है बेसिकली
पहले कमांड है
दूसरी कमांड होती है
जो आप लोग उसे नहीं करते वैसे है
एप्टीट्यूड
होती है
कौन-कौन से पैकेज इंस्टॉल है
डीपी के जी डीपी के जी आईफोन ल करूंगा तो
मेरे को आपको पता चला की आपकी मशीन में
कितने पैकेज इंस्टॉल है देखो अब ये शो कर
रहा है वन तू ऐसे ये दे सारे के सारे को
पैकेट है देखो 34 बहुत साड़ी पेज हैं अब
ये क्या है की लाइक मोर रिलैक्स कमांड की
तरह ओपन हुआ है फिट कर देता हूं तो इसने
वो सारे पैकेज
आपके सामने शो कर दी जितने भी आपके मशीन
में इंस्टॉल्ड है अगर आपको किसी पैकेज की
वजह अब ये चेक करना चाहते हो पर एग्जांपल
मेरा कोई पैकेज है इसमें उठाता हूं मैं
ऑलरेडी
देखना चाहता हूं की इस पैकेज की वजह से
कौन-कौन सी फाइल हमारी मशीन में इंस्टॉल
हो गई है
अब इसमें उन साड़ी फाइल्स की लिस्ट आपकी
स्क्रीन के सामने प्रिंट कर दी जो इस
पैकेज की
वजह से आपकी मशीन में इंस्टॉल हुई है अगर
मैं किसी एक फाइल की डिटेल देखना चाहता
हूं की इस फाइल को किस पैकेज की वजह से
इंस्टॉल किया गया है पर एग्जांपल में
देखिए फाइल है
[संगीत]
आपकी मशीन में है तो यह भी देख सकते
हो
अपनी मशीन में देखने को मिल रही है मतलब
इसको किसने इंस्टॉल किया है
अगर आपको उन साड़ी फाइल्स को देखना चाहते
हैं जो पर्टिकुलर पैकेज की वजह से इंस्टॉल
अल्ट डीएस
अब बात करते हैं
अब इसमें हम वो पैकेज इंस्टॉल करते हैं जो
हम बेसिकली क्या करते हैं गूगल करते हैं
वहां से किसी प्रकार
करते हैं और उसको क्या करते हैं
दी आई बी एक्सटेंशन है ओके अगर आपको अपनी
मशीन में किसी भी पैकेज को अनइनस्टॉल करना
है रिमूव करना है अगर रिमूव करना है तो
कैसे करोगे डीपी के जी
आईफोन आर लगा दूंगा ओनली आई की जगह मैं
उसे करूंगा मतलब रिमूव करना है वो करके
दिखा रहा है इसको लेकिन ये रिमूव कर दो
लेकिन एक चीज ध्यान रखना डीपी क कमांड के
कैसे में हमें
डिपेंडेंसी को मैन्युअल रिजॉल्व करना होगा
जो मैं बात कर रहा था एक एग्जांपल दे रहा
था उन सारे डिपेंडेंसी को
ठीक है हम उन साड़ी डिपेंडेंसी को क्या
करना पड़ेगा
इंस्टॉल करते हैं तो अगर किसी पैकेज की
डिपेंडेंसी नहीं है तो वह इंस्टॉल हो
जाएगा एडरवाइज आपको क्या करना है आपको
उसकी साड़ी की साड़ी डिपेंडेंसी
उसे कर सकते हैं जो काफी आपके लिए
बेनिफिशियल है अब बात करते हैं
अब अगर आपको अपनी मशीन को अपडेट करना है
अपग्रेड करना कैसे करेंगे तो कैसे करते
हैं
लेकिन
गेट अपडेट
ऐसे उसे की जाति थी लेकिन आजकल का गेट
लगाने की जरूर नहीं है पीपीटी कैट अपडेट्स
अब ये क्या करेगा की आपकी मशीन में अपडेट
कर देगा आपको अपनी मशीन को अगर अपडेट करना
है तो हम ऐसे कर सकते हैं
अगर आपको अपनी मशीन को अपग्रेड करना है तो
एप्ट गेट करेंगे
ओके क्योंकि मेरा क्या है अपडेट है
कंटिन्यू अभी क्या होता है की
आपकी जो जितने भी आपकी मशीन में पैकेजिंग
इंस्टॉल होते हैं या अपडेट करते हैं यह
अपडेट करते हैं वो पैकेज हमारी मशीन में
एक लोकल लोकेशन होती है वहां पर जाकर क्या
होता है डाउनलोड
लोकेशन कहां पर होती है मैं एलएस करता हूं
क्या इसमें है कैसे है अप
उसके बाद एक होती है
आर्काइव्स
लिमिटेड
करता राहत हूं तो इसलिए यहां पर वो
इनफार्मेशन है जाति है अगर क्या करना
चाहता हूं सारे पैकेज को आप बताना चाहते
हैं तो मैं क्या उसे कर सकता हूं पीपीटी
गेट क्लीन सी ल आई ए एन क्लीन मी उसे कर
सकता हूं
अब ये क्या है इसको क्या कहते हैं अब
इसमें क्या बिल्कुल क्लियर कर दिया तो
इसलिए यहां पर बहुत कम पैकेज आपको देखने
को मिल रहे हैं क्योंकि यहां पर वो मशीन
मैंने क्या कर रहे थे क्लीन करता राहत हूं
जैसे आज क्लीन कर दिया
तो अगर इसके अंदर आपको सर्च करना होता तो
आप सिंपली अगर आपको अपने
अंदर आपको सर्च ऑपरेशन परफॉर्म करना हो तो
आप क्या करते हैं एप्ट
एचएससी
सर्च करना पड़ता उसके बाद उसे पैकेज का
आपको नाम देना पड़ता है
पैकेज नाम
अब मैं क्योंकि हमने क्लीन कर दिया कोई
फायदा नहीं है अभी
टेंडर अब बात करते हैं की किसी भी पैकेज
को आप अपनी मशीन में कैसे इंस्टॉल कर सकते
हैं किसी भी पैकेज को आप अपनी मशीन में
कैसे इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं तो सिंपली कैसे
करते हैं आपको पता है
और पैकेज का नाम
पर एग्जांपल
[संगीत]
देखना पड़ेगा
आईटी बिल सो टेक सो मैच टाइम ओके ये है तो
मैं दिखा रहा हूं एप्ट अब मैं क्या कहना
चाहता हूं एप्ट
गेट और इंस्टॉल
कर दिया जो मैंने ढूंढा आपकी अपनी मशीन
में अब इस पैकेट
किसने किया गया आपकी मशीन उसे पैकेज को
इंस्टॉल कर दिया अगर आपको किसी पैकेज
वगैरा रिमूव करना हो तो कैसे करोगे ए पी
टी
गेट रिमूव आर एक ओ वे रिमूव
किया था कंट्रोल
कर दिया
अब एक चीज है की अगर आप किसी पैकेज को
रिमूव करते टाइम ही उसकी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
फाइल को भी रिमूव कर दो क्या की मैंने जो
रिमूव किया ओनली पैकेज इंस्टॉल रिमूव किया
इसकी कंफीग्रेशन फाइल अभी तक रिमूव नहीं
हो अगर आप क्या चाहते हो की अगर पैकेज
रिमूव करते हो उसकी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल को
भी साथ में रिमूव करना है आप नहीं रखना
चाहते
हो
छोड़ के चली जाए अगर ऐसा कुछ करना चाहते
तो आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा इसको इंस्टॉल
करके दिखा देता हूं फिर से रिपीट इंस्टॉल
करके दिखाएंगे उसके लिए कमांड होती है
अपग्रेड का मतलब लकी क्या करता है ना की
उसको जो भी आपके ऑलरेडी सॉफ्टवेयर है उनको
अपडेट कर देता है आपके प्रेजेंट उसके साथ
जैसे आपकी मोबाइल में सॉफ्टवेयर अपडेट आते
रहते हैं वो ओल्ड वर्जन को
रिमूव करके नया वर्जन हो जाता है ऐसे ही
इसमें हो जाता है अपग्रेड करोगे लेटेस्ट
उसके साथ अपग्रेड होना स्टार्ट होता है तो
अब मुझे क्या करना है ट उसके लिए होती है
गेट पर
जी पर
उसके बाद उसे पैकेज का नाम
फाइल के साथ ही इसको क्या कर दिया रिमूव
कर देगा यस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल के साथ ही
रिमूव कर देगा बस इतना ही अंतर है की जब
एप्ट आप रिमूव उसे करते हैं
तो क्या करता हूं इंस्टॉल करता है अब यह
क्या है विद कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल उसको क्या
करता अनइनस्टॉल कर देता है अगर आप तीसरी
कमांड की बात करते हैं एप्टीट्यूड अगर
आपको एप्टीट्यूड कमांड को उसे करना है
उसके लिए आपकी मशीन में एप्टीट्यूड पैकेट
का इंस्टॉल होना जरूरी है एप्ट इंस्टॉल
एप्टीट्यूड आप टेबल पी एप्टीट्यूड ये होगा
ना अब टी आई टी
यह पैकेज आपकी मशीन
ओके ऑलरेडी मेरी मशीन में था इसलिए क्या
है ये शो करता है तो अभी क्या है अगर आपको
इसको उसे करना था एप्ट इंस्टॉल आपको फिर
से कमांड दिखता हूं ये कमांड एप्ट इंस्टॉल
एप्टीट्यूड मैं कमेंट आउट करके दिखा देता
हूं
ये रहा
आपको स्क्रीन पर दिखाई दे रहा होगा अगर आप
इस कमांड को उसे करना बिल्कुल एक्जेक्टली
कम करती है बिल्कुल जैसे
एटीट्यूड
कम करती है
एक चीज है इसके साथ की अगर आप क्या कर
सकते हो की आपको अपनी मशीन को सेफ्ली पैच
करना चाहते हैं अब ग्रेट का मतलब पैच भी
बोल सकते हो आप अगर
बोल सकते हो अगर आप क्या करते हो
आपको अपडेट करना चाहते हो तो उससे क्या
फायदा होगा
ये रहेगा की आपकी मशीन है ना
हेलो
चांसेस कम हो जाएंगे जो इस समय वह कम हो
सकते हैं उसको कैसे उसे कर सकते हो
एप्टीट्यूड अपडेट उसके बाद आपको क्या है
क्या करोगे
अपडेट करते वक्त
तो ये क्या है शॉप अपग्रेड उसे करोगे इसका
मतलब क्या की आप अपनी मशीन को एक सेफ मोड
में अपग्रेड कर रहे हो जिससे क्या है की
जो एरर्स है या कुछ इशू होने की जो चांसेस
है वे कम हो जाएगी आपकी मशीन में अगर आपको
कमांड की एप्लीकेशन इंस्टॉल करना है तो
कैसे करोगे एप्टीट्यूड मैं बस आपको कमेंट
दाल करके दिखा देता हूं इंस्टॉल
कर देगा
इंस्टॉल
का नाम बादल गया है
अब बात करते हैं
अगर आप किसी पैकेट को सर्च करना है तो
उसके लिए भी आप कर सकते क्या कर सकते हो
सर्च और पैकेज का नाम सर्च करना है जैसे
मैंने सर्च किया है तो सर्च कहां पर करेगा
आपके डिपॉजिटरी के अंदर अगर आप क्या आपको
नहीं मालूम की आपके रिपोजिटरी में वो
पैकेज है या नहीं है तो उसके लिए अप्लाई
करोगे
सिंपली पैकेज का क्या है छोटे से कुछ शब्द
जो आपको लगता है की ये हो सकता है उसका
नाम तो वो लिखिए और इंटर कर दिया तो आपको
जो ट्रेन में सर्च करके दिखाए जैसे मैंने
अभी एचटीटीपी सर्च
ब्लू यू स स को इंस्टॉल
करें की इनफॉरमेशन काफी देखने में मिलती
है हम आपको दिखता हूं
मिलती है और ये क्या है रिपोजिटरी की
लोकेशन
कन्फ्यूजन नहीं है तो एक कम कीजिए आप मेरी
देख के कर लीजिए एडरवाइज आपको सीधा सा
ऑप्शन चाहिए
आप सिंपली क्या करना है
आपको क्या करना है
काली लाइनेक्स
आईपॉजिटरी फाइल
देखो बिल्कुल इसमें जो लेटेस्ट
आप क्या कर सकते हो
एक तरीका है अगर आपको कॉन्फ़िगर करना है
आपको अपनी मशीन को आपकी मशीन में अगर क्या
है ट कमांड उसे कर रहे हो किसी पैकेज
इंस्टॉल करना है अपडेट करना अपडेट करना है
कुछ प्रॉब्लम्स ए रही है तो आप क्या कर
सकते हो ऐसे कर सकते हो
यहां पर देखने को मिल शक्ति है दूसरा क्या
कई बार आपके बाहर भी देखने को मिल जाति है
कहां पर है पर एग्जांपल अगर मैं दिखाऊं
काली के ऑफिशल पेज पर सबसे अच्छी मिलेगी
इनफॉरमेशन भी आपको देखने को मिल रही है तो
यहां पर से भी कट कॉपी पेस्ट करना है और
आपको क्या करना है इनेबल डिसएबल कर सकते
हो ओके ये है आपका रेगुलेटर कॉन्फ़िगर
करने का तरीका जिसकी भी कोई भी इशू आया था
आप इशू नहीं आना चाहिए फिर ठीक है आपको
ऐसे करना है तो ये है आपके वो कंफीग्रेशन
फाइल यहां पर क्या वो पाठ दिया जाता है
जहां पर आपके सिस्टम की आपके मशीन की
रिपोजिटरीज लोकेटेड है यह अगर आपको क्या
करना है या तो सिंपली आपको क्या करना है
इसको क्या कर सकते हो इस फाइल को
डायरेक्टली ओपन करके एडिट कर सकते हो कट
कॉपी पेस्ट करते हो अदर वाइस कुछ कमांड का
थ्रू भी कर सकते हो कैसे मैं कमांड को लिख
के बताता हूं
दास पीपीटी
आर ए पी ओ एस आई टी ओ आर ए पॉजिटिव
कमांड है अगर उसे कमांड का कलर चेंज नहीं
होता है वो ओनली व्हाइट राहत है इसका मतलब
वो एक कमांड है ही नहीं पैकेज आपकी मशीन
में है नहीं तो एड ए पीटी रिपोजिटरी उसके
बाद आपको क्या करना है सिंपली क्या लिखना
है मैं यूआरएल यूआरएल
ऑफ डी
प्रोजेक्ट इमेज
कॉपी यहां पर कंट्रोल
यह एक छोटा सा उसे ऑफ पैकेज मैनेजमेंट तो
इस तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो आपकी मशीन
में पैकेज को मैनेज कर सकते हो आपकी मशीन
के अंदर ओके तो अब आप क्या कर सकते हो
आपको पैकेज अगर इंस्टॉल करने हो अनइनस्टॉल
करने हो सर्च करना हो आपकी मशीन के अंदर
सर्च करना हो तो तीन तरीके से कर सकते हो
एक तो लोकल कमांड होती है डीपीके ए पी टी
होती है और एप्टीट्यूड होती है और ये
रिपोजिटरी फाइल आपकी कहां पे कॉन्फ़िगर
होती है आपको पता चल गया होगा कोई इस हुआ
तो आपको क्या करना है अगर पैकेज इंस्टॉल
नहीं हो रहे या कुछ भी ए रहा तो आप क्या
कर सकते हो चेक कर सकते हैं रेफ्रिजरेटर
है नहीं अगर सही से कॉन्फ़िगर है तो आप
वर्चुअल मशीन उसे करें तो सोमेटाइम्स क्या
ये शो होता है ये जो बॉक्स होते हैं या
बीएमडब्ल्यू और सम टाइम्स किसी एडेप्टर पे
कम कर रहा था डॉक्टर कौन सही बात कर रहा
हूं पर एग्जांपल आपको देखने को मिलेगा
आपको जब राइट क्लिक करोगे या फिर सेटिंग
में जाओगे और यहां पर नेटवर्क सेटिंग
नेटवर्क यहां पर ब्रिज नेट पोस्ट ओनली
कस्टम लैंड तो आपको जब इनमें से कई बार हो
सकता है की ब्रिज मोड में वो कम करना बैंड
कर जाए तो आपको क्या करना है सिंपली नेट
मोड को चेंज करके देख लेना चाहिए या होस्ट
ओनली को चेंज करके देखना चाहिए क्या इन
तीनों कैसे में मोस्ट ओनली को मत करना एक
अलग प्राइवेट नेटवर्क की बात करता है तो
इन दोनों में शिफ्ट करके देख लो क्या तब
भी नहीं कम करता है इसका मतलब क्या है या
तो आपके लिए शायरी वाला सर्वर थोड़ा सा डॉ
हो गया थोड़ा सा वेट कीजिए अगर इनमें
शिफ्ट करने के बाद अगर आपका कम करें इसका
मतलब क्या इनमें से ऊपर वाला डॉक्टर ढंग
से कम नहीं कर रहा है क्योंकि कुछ
मिस कंफीग्रेशन है कुछ ग्लिच है की इसके
अंदर एमवेयर के अंदर आपकी या तो उसको
अपडेट करने से कुछ हुआ या कुछ भी हुआ होगा
तो ऐसे ही उसे करना है एडरवाइज क्या होगा
फिर दो ऑप्शन आप चेक कर चुके हैं तीसरा
फिर आपको आपकी जो लिस्ट है उसको चेक करना
है उसमें कोई प्रॉब्लम तो नहीं है अगर ये
तीनों चीज चेक कर लिया फिर भी आपकी मशीन
में ये प्रॉब्लम्स ए रही है पैकेट इंस्टॉल
नहीं हो का रहे तो एक-दो बार स्टार्ट करके
थोड़ा वेट कीजिए तब भी नहीं हो का रहा तो
सिंपली आपकी मशीन का वर्जन लीजिए वर्जन
लेने के बाद आपको सिंपली क्या करना है
काली की ऑफिशल वेबसाइट पे जाना जो मैंने
बताया वहां से जो भी लेटेस्ट वाला यूआरएल
है उसको कट कॉपी पेस्ट करना उसे टाइम
परफॉर्म करने और आपकी मशीन पहले शायरी कम
करना स्टार्ट कर दे दी इतना करने के बाद
आज तक तो किसी के प्रॉब्लम हुई नहीं है
अगर किसी की भी होती है तो फिर देखते हैं
लेकिन अभी तक किसी के इस चेस में कोई
प्रॉब्लम हुई नहीं है तो आप ऐसे कर सकते
हो कॉन्फ़िगर आपकी मशीन के अंदर पैकेज तो
आज का टॉपिक यह था
आज का टॉपिक आपको समझ में आएगा बताइए अभी
तक ये दोनों कोड कमांड और पैकेज मैनेजमेंट
समझ में आया नहीं आया बताइए
चलो थोड़ा सा करते हैं 10 मिनट का
टॉपिक के बड़े में सीखने हैं कुछ कंट्रोल
ऑपरेटर के बड़े में सीखने हैं सॉरी
बात करते हैं क्लियर कर देता है
जो पहले बात तो कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर क्या होते
हैं देखो कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर का उसे हम क्यों
करते हैं कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर कम उसे करते हैं
मल्टीपल कमांड को एक साथ एग्जीक्यूट करने
के लिए कमांड को दूसरी कमांड से जोड़ने के
लिए समझ में आया कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर का बेसिक
परपज क्या है की आपको एक साथ में
मल्टीपल कमांड फायर करनी है तो आप क्या कर
सकते हो कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर का उसे कर सकते
हैं
सबसे पहले हम कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर के बड़े में
बात करते हैं जो पहले वाला जो कंट्रोल
ऑपरेटर है जिसका नाम है
सेमी कलर
कंट्रोल ओपेरा कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर
अब क्या होता है की कई बार हमें मल्टीपल
कमांड को एक साथ एग्जीक्यूट करना होता है
तो ऐसे में हमें सिरौली कमांड को एग्जिट
करना होता है मतलब एक के बाद एक सीरियल्ली
पर एग्जांपल मैंने क्या किया डेट कमांड है
जिसे डेट कमाने में देखा हो फिर ये 150 कर
रहा है पीडी कमांड क्या है ओके ये बता रहा
है अब मैं क्या करूं कल कमांड कैलेंडर को
बता रहा है ये तीनों कमांड है मैं क्या कर
सकता हूं एक साथ उसे कर सकता हूं की
बार-बार टाइप करने के बाद मैं क्या करूंगा
डेट को मैंने लिया उसके बाद उसके बाद क्या
है कैलेंडर किया उसके बाद शैली में सेमी
कोलोन उसके बाद मैंने क्या कर दिया पीडी
कर दिया सिंपली हिट और इसने क्या कर दिया
पहले डेट कमांडर कमांड को अब एक चीज ध्यान
में रखना जरूर ऑपरेट करता है लेकिन इसको
फर्क नहीं पड़ता की पहले कमांड फेल हुई या
पास हुई ये क्या करता है अगर उसका आउटपुट
एरर है तो एरर स्क्रीन पर शो करेगा
और अगर उसका सक्सेसफुल है सक्सेसफुल
आउटपुट तो वह भी शो करेगा मतलब इसको फर्क
नहीं पड़ता की पहले कमांड एग्जीक्यूट हुई
या नहीं हुई है उसे पर डिपेंडेंट नहीं
करता लेकिन ये सीरीज में कम करता है पहले
फिर दूसरी ऐसे कम करता है वो एग्जांपल मैं
जेनरेट करता हूं जड़ डेट कोई कमांड नहीं
है और उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं कल
कमांड उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं पीडी
कमांड देखिए जब डेट को ये कमांड नहीं है
अभी रिजल्ट का एरर आपकी स्क्रीन पे शो कर
दिया उसके बाद कैलेंडर का आउटपुट उसके बाद
ये आउटपुट नेक्स्ट ऑपरेटर जो आता है सेकंड
ऑपरेटर की बात करते हैं जिसका सेकंड
ऑपरेटर ये है आपका सेकंड ऑपरेटर की बात
करते हो
एम परसेंट ऑपरेटर सेकंड नंबर पर जो आता है
आपका वो है
इसको ये क्या कम करता है ये भी मल्टीपल
कमांड्स को एग्जीक्यूट करवाने के कम आता
है लेकिन ये क्या करता है पैरेलल ही
पहले कम करता है पर एग्जांपल कैसे मैंने
क्या किया डेट और
परसेंट
स्क्रीनशॉट
कर दिया इसका मतलब क्या है की जो कमांड
पहले एग्जीक्यूटिव इसने क्या करते हैं एक
को बैकग्राउंड डाला दूसरे को पैरेलल साथ
के साथ करवाया लेकिन जिसका आउटपुट पहले
आएगा वो स्क्रीन पे शो हो जाएगा लेकिन
आउटपुट दोनों का ही आएगा पर एग्जांपल
मैंने क्या किया डेट कमांड किया और
ओके डेट और दो ही कमांड करवाऊंगी मैं
तीसरी देख लेते हैं कम करेगी डेट और कल
डेट और पीडी के मैंने
उसके बाद मैंने क्या कर दिया क्या किया
जैसे पहले दो को डाला उसके बाद इसका प
दिया से टाइम जब स्क्रीन पर उसके बाद
कैलेंडर का आउटपुट आने वाला था उसके बाद
एक की जब दान डेट का आउटपुट ए गया उसके
बाद दूसरी जब
इस तरीके से एक साथ कमांड को एग्जीक्यूट
करवाता है लेकिन
थर्ड नंबर में जो कंट्रोल रहा है उसके बाद
करते हैं उसको वह क्वेश्चन मार्क वह आपका
है क्वेश्चन मार्क
क्वेश्चन मार्क
[संगीत]
कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर
की क्या वो सक्सेसफुल एग्जीक्यूट हुई थी
या नहीं बेसिकली
हम क्या करते हैं
तो उसको हम बोलते हैं
कैसे क्रिएट होते हैं वह भी हम इसमें
सीखने वाले हैं
हम सीखेंगे
या तो वह क्या होती है जीरो होती है या वह
आपकी प्रीवियस कमांड
सक्सेसफुल हुई है तो इसका मतलब आपको
वैल्यू जीरो आएगी अगर आपकी प्रीवियस कमांड
सक्सेसफुल एग्जीक्यूटिव तो उसकी वैल्यू
क्या आएगी वन या कोई भी रेंडम वैल्यू ए
जाएगी डिपेंड ऑन डी डिपेंड्स ऑन डी मशीन
तो बात करते हैं पर एग्जांपल मैं कैसे
मैंने क्या किया एक्वा करता हूं मैंने को
किया डॉलर
पीडी दे रहा हूं मैं डॉलर एक वेरिएबल है
एक सिस्टम डिफाइंड वैरियेबल्स है जिसकी प
वाली यही से आते है देखो ये एक वैरियेबल्स
है
क्योंकि एक वेरिएबल है ना ये तो ठीक है हम
स्टार्ट करते हैं
सक्सेसफुल हुए थे इसलिए का रहे थे शो कर
दिया रिजल्ट अब मैंने का दिया जड़ सी ए ल
ल ओ मैंने कुछ भी कमांड फायर कर दी आईटी
इंटर अब ये कमांड सक्सेसफुल नहीं हुई थी
ओके मैं को डॉलर क्वेश्चन मार्क करता हूं
ये 127 मैंने क्या बोला कोई भी रेंडम
वैल्यू इसका मतलब क्या की जो मेरी
प्रीवियस कमांड थी उसका आउटपुट अगर अदर
दें जीरो आया इसका मतलब सक्सेसफुल नहीं
हुई थी अब ये क्या है की आईटी इस वेरी
हेल्पफुल इन बेस्ट 15 की आपके कमांड
एग्जीक्यूट नहीं हुई ये सब चीज ट्रैक करने
के लिए काफी हेल्पफुल होता है ये हमारी
बेस्ट 15 में तो ये था आपका एक क्वेश्चन
मार्क ऑपरेटर है अब बात करते हैं जो हमारा
फोर्थ ओके फोर्थ ऑपरेटर है जो है हमारा
जिसकी जिसका नाम है
जिसको और ऑपरेटर बोलते हैं
या हम क्या बोल सकते हैं
की किसी ने अगर क्योंकि आप सभी 12 अपने
पास आउट किया है तो वहां पर
देखो मिलते हैं तो और का मतलब क्या होता
है
कंडीशन वन और कंडीशन तो एडमिन क्या कर दो
कंडीशन लेते हैं अगर दोनों ही कंडीशन ट्रू
है तो आउटपुट उनका ट्रू होगा तो यह कमांड
क्या करें सक्सेसफुल आपका आउटपुट शो करेगी
अगर कंडीशन वन और तू में से किसी आउटपुट
अगर जल है तो क्या होगा
उसका जो फाइनल आउटपुट होगा वो क्या होगा
पोल होगा आई रिपीट अगेन अगर कंडीशन वन
ट्रू है अगर कंडीशन तू भी ट्रू है दोनों
ही कंडीशन अगर ट्रू है इसका मतलब क्या है
उसका ट्रू होगा अगर दोनों कंडीशन में कोई
भी एक कंडीशन अगर पल्स है तो आप फॉल्स
आएगा यह और ऑपरेटर की बात अब बात करें पर
एग्जांपल मैंने क्या किया
फिर फर्स्ट मैंने क्या किया
है क्योंकि जो कंडीशन वन थी ये भी ट्रू थी
और कंडीशन तू थी ये भी तू थी अब बात करते
हैं नेक्स्ट अब मैंने क्या किया की जो
कंडीशन वन है उसको मैंने का दिया जल स ए
को कर दिया हिट इंटर अब इसने क्या का दिया
क्योंकि कंडीशन तू डी ट्रू थी ना लेकिन
कंडीशन वन फोर्थ से इसलिए इसने क्या इसका
आउटपुट में एड्रेस दिखा दिया प्रॉब्लम शो
कर दी अगर यही कम है क्या ठीक है मेरी
कंडीशन तू में प्रॉब्लम है अगर कंडीशन तू
मेरी क्या है जल है और लेकिन कंडीशन
शो करेगा नेक्स्ट ऑपरेटर है आपका
जो है उसको हम बोलते हैं लॉजिकल ऑपरेटर
लॉजिकल और ऑपरेटर जिसके लिए हम उसे करते
हैं
बोल सकते हैं
जिसको हम बोलेंगे
आपको पता है लॉजिकल ऑपरेटर में कोई भी एक
कंडीशन
है ठीक है फैक्ट्री
कर रहा हूं मैं डबल पाइप से मिलता है अब
ये देखना एक चीज देखना इन्होंने फर्स्ट
आउटपुट हो गया देखो
लॉजिकल और मैं क्या होता है की अगर आपकी
पहले कंडीशन ट्रू हो गई तो सेकंड कंडीशन
पे जाएगा नहीं पहले कंडीशन की आउटपुट को
शो कर देगा मतलब यह तो यह अगर यह नहीं तो
ये इसका मतलब होता है
अगर मुझे क्या कर दिया अगर मैंने सेकंड
फर्स्ट कंडीशन में क्या कर दिया रंग कर
दिया
उसको क्या कर दिया स्क्रीन पे सो गया की
भैया जो जड़ी को कमांड है वो आपकी गलत है
उसका ये एरर है और उसके बाद उसने क्या
किया जाए सेकंड का पूरा स्क्रीन पे शो कर
दिया सेकंड कंडीशन में तभी जाएगा पहले
कंडीशन में फॉल्स हो गई थी आपकी और ऑपरेटर
की कहानी अब क्या होता है की हम अब इन
दोनों ऑपरेटर को एक साथ में उसे कर सकते
हैं
उसे करने के लिए पर एग्जांपल
कस्ट इंटर है मेरे पास यह फाइल
एस मैं कंडीशन स्टेटमेंट बना दिया
आईटी फील्स क्योंकि जो कंडीशन थी जो
कंडीशन थी इसमें क्या किया फूल फिल्म
आयोग किया तीन टॉपिक हमने क्लियर करने थे
हमारे हो गए कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर और उसके बाद
मैंने पैकेज मैनेजमेंट का इंट्रोडक्शन दे
दिया थोड़ा सा पैकेज मैनेजमेंट कैसे करना
है तीसरा मैंने क्या बताया आप लोगों को जो
बताया लॉकेट कमांड के बड़े में
कैप्सूल कोर्स वे हैव थ्री डेज लेफ्ट दे
आर सम टॉपिक लेफ्ट जिम से सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट
कमांड एक से कमांड के बड़े में बताऊंगा और
एक मैं बताऊंगा थोड़ा सा और टॉपिक बैक गया
आपका इसी में हिस्ट्री कमांड और वो दो तीन
डेज में काफी अच्छे से करेंगे हम तो उसे
करने वाले हम अपना कैप्सूल कोर्स और आयोग
की और एंजॉयिंग डी मी कोर्स अगर आप लोगों
की शिकायत है आपको लगता है की हमारा कोर्स
अच्छा नहीं है नोट गुड पर यू और नोट डी
कंटेंट कंटेंट नहीं है इसमें कुछ नहीं है
तो यह वेरी ओपन तू फ्री तू कमेंट नेगेटिव
कमेंट आई हैव नो प्रॉब्लम
अपना 100% प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं क्योंकि जी
लेवल पर सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर आपको इस टाइम
पे जितना लेने प्रोवाइड करना चाहिए मैं
बाकी लोगों से ज्यादा प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं
जितना आपको पता होना चाहिए जितना डिटेल
में बताना चाहिए क्योंकि कहानी भी कोर्स
करने जाओगे तो इतना डीटेल्स में आपको
देखने को नहीं मिलेगा
कहानी भी तीन क्लास की होती नहीं आपका
पोस्ट फिनिश कर दिया जाता है बट मैं इस
टाइप से नहीं करता मेरा तरीका अलग है मैं
ऐसे ही पढ़ा था वो सीखने को मिले ताकि
टाइम पास करने के लिए
वैसे भी धीरे-धीरे हमारे क्या है की
लाइव क्लासेस डेटिंग
कोई बात नहीं मुझे फर्क नहीं पड़ेगा तो
दे दे
बाय बाय गुड नाइट
टेक केयर